with its unique story and lovable cast
of characters few science fiction
features from the 1980s are as memorable
as Back to the Future one of the film's
co-stars Claudia grace wells was a
standout but her profile would drop
significantly in the years following the
film's release here's what she's been up
to since the first act of Marty McFly's
time-traveling adventure introduces us
to the zany residents of Hill Valley
California
the 1985 version aside from getting
viewers acquainted with Doc Brown
Marty's eccentric father George and the
highly punchable Biff Tannen the first
installments of Back to the Future
offered the initial introduction to
Jennifer Jane Parker Marty's girlfriend
and future wife a quintessential 1980s
dream girl does your mom know about
tomorrow night get out of town my my fix
I'm gone careful with the guys although
the role of Jennifer Parker will be
played and voiced by several other
notable actresses throughout the life of
the franchise including Elisabeth Shue
who took over love-interest duties in
the sequel any fan of Back to the Future
would tell you that the real Jennifer
Parker was and always will be Claudia
great swells well Sony played the part
in the original Back to the Future but
she left a mark on the character that
endures to this day unsurprisingly this
reagan-era starlet remains as radiant as
ever and she's actually been up to some
pretty interesting things since starring
in an iconic piece of American cinema
although Welles was born in Malaysia she
grew up in the San Francisco Bay Area
and moved to Los Angeles as a young teen
where she immediately became interested
in acting
she graduated from Beverly Hills High
School and soon after started appearing
on a number of popular TV series of the
time Welles landed guest spots on family
and Strikeforce plus a five episode arc
on Herbie the lovebug just to name a few
Welles go next door appeal served her
well in the early years of her career
and as the TV roles continue to pour in
she finally got a big break but Welles
almost had to bail on Back to the Future
because a pilot she had have recently
joined for ABC got picked up and she was
contractually obligated to follow
through on the shoots the early days of
back to the futures production featured
a bizarro world version of the cast we
know and love today Eric Stoltz played
the role of Marty McFly and the officers
melora hardin was cast opposite him in
the role of Jennifer by the time Welles
shooting a pilot director Robert
Zemeckis puts a halt on filming Back to
the Future and recast a young
up-and-comer named Michael J Fox in the
leading role with a calendar clear
well stepped in to claim the part she
had originally been handed and the rest
is history
Back to the Future Lost Wells for the
heights of teen stardom and she seemed
poised to conquer the industry she
appeared on one more major 1986 project
a short-lived television adaptation of
Fast Times at Ridgemont High
and then from Lee disappeared from the
limelight it was a stunning vanishing
act one hardly explained away by the
canceled series so where did she go
it's rare for a young star with an
entire career ahead of her to simply
walk away but Welles made her premature
exit for a noble cause surely after the
release of Back to the Future and the
subsequent cancellation of fast times
her mother was diagnosed with cancer
Welles immediately puts her career on
hold and returned home to care for her
ailing parents throughout the treatment
process Welles mother was intimately
involved in her career even serving in
an official capacity as her manager as
Welles told people for a 2015 profile I
just didn't have it in me to do anything
but deal with the stress and the
emotions that were going on as a result
of my mom being in the process of dying
I just wasn't in a place to be able to
think about my career or the film or
anything other than what I was doing
with my own life life was very very
difficult and stressful as for how she
felt about Elisabeth Shue slipping into
the role she made famous well said when
I found out she was cast I was actually
very flattered and honored because I
think she's an amazing actress and funny
enough the lead role of adventures in
babysitting was between her me and
Phoebe Cates I have nothing but respect
and praise for her and I still have not
met her
sadly Welles mother did indeed succumb
to her disease and the last upended
Welles life to the point that she felt
unable to return to acting for the
better part of a decade fortunately that
isn't where Claudia wells story ends in
1994 wells suckered talents at a San
Fernando Valley
opening a high-end menswear shop in
Studio City called Imani Wells
with Wells serving in the dual capacity
of owner and manager Imani wells
flourished in service for almost 30
years Imani wells success proves that
its owner is much more than just a
pretty face
Wells told people I opened it partially
because I wanted a financial base
so I could go back to acting on my terms
where if a role is some right or if it's
not a project I want to do I could say
no I wouldn't be desperate or hungry I
can go back to acting she did in 1996
wells dipped a toe into the acting pond
by starring in the indie film
Stillwater's burn after a long hiatus
she appeared in the 2011 low-budget
sci-fi disaster film alien Armageddon
since then Welles has worked on enough
appearing on the hit CBS drama that
Mentalist the same year and even
reprising the role of Jennifer Parker an
Italian video game from 2015 is slightly
mean version of her sweet so Welles
doesn't seem to be slowing down anytime
soon either her next film is the action
titled Quinn and she has three more
follow-up projects in pre-production or
early developments as of the making of
this video once the industry gets back
on its feet we're sure we'll be seeing
plenty of Marty McFly's original muse on
the silver screen check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]